are you ready for the rules here we go
number one is a great rule that actually
jason you were reminding me how valuable
this was um
when we were pitching and i was thinking
about the word
think and how weak that can sound
especially when you're pitching to
investors
and other female advisors reminded me of
this as well you
know right and so i feel like my female
friends are most guilty of this
but when you're writing you want to use
powerful words that credit you as the
authority
of the subject whatever it is so don't
undercut yourself
with weak words the weak words are need
the needy team needs right we need your
money
think like i said you want to do no i
just wanted to
say something something right see how
that's a little fluffy there
probably maybe possibly these are all
kind of teetering words now there are
places for these words
um sometimes in customer service when
you want to put yourself on the down
foot to you know make yourself feel more
accessible
but but this is a general idea you want
to be the boss
of what you're saying and be the
authority